all right here's the first story from
the post-millennial writing about me
very quickly so I thought it was really
funny because we were pulling up stories
and I'm like what's the biggest news of
the day is it the recession that we are
in that Biden's denying and then Lydia
pulls up breaking breaking news Tim
Poole goes to war with Twitter over
groomer controversy journalist Tim Poole
went to war with Twitter on Monday after
the social media platform locked him out
of his account for criticizing groomers
and I just I just went off I pulled up a
whole bunch of stories about Twitter
protecting pedophiles like not they also
blocked me from posting ads I got two
emails one said your account is locked
and the other says you are now
ineligible to post advertisements on
Twitter did you ever yeah yeah oh I read
I did an ad Run for the song we did Will
of the people you got like three million
views well and okay like I was like wow
that's actually better than YouTube so
hey maybe Twitter's a good medium for
putting the stuff not anymore apparently
they said you're blocked forever they
just said my account is now ineligible
to run ads oh okay all because I had to
tweet I can't even pull it up they make
you delete it there was an image I saw
and it showed adult men showing sexual
things to Children wow overtly it this
is this was not an issue of like a dude
reading a book yeah this was an issue of
I think it was like a dude reading a
book pointing to sexual things or
something like that I honestly can't
remember but like you guys know me
people are like Tim's offensive or why
would he do something like this there
are people on Twitter who will just call
out overtly anyone as a groomer mine was
like I was making a literal point
they're like hey look at this this is
not just some dude reading a book this
is overt grooming of children they
locked me out and told me I had to
delete it wow so I don't I don't think
Twitter matters all that much to be
honest the the amount of people who saw
that tweet is in the few thousand it's
like tens of thousands and I was like
who cares like what's the impact on
society going to be if a bunch of people
like me on Twitter see this thing I
don't care about what do I do on Twitter
I I you know ish post and I make the
blue techie journalists freak out when I
post nonsense that's more valuable so
the only people who actually see stuff
on Twitter are journalists and I guess
other commentators so there's no real
public value to it so I just deleted it
but here's ultimately where we get to
I'll read you a few of these stories
Evie magazine Twitter is a breeding
ground for the normalization of
pedophilia Daily Dot Twitter cues of
lighting pedophiles discuss their sexual
attraction to Children AP Twitter is not
placing sex offender notices on sex
offender accounts wow the next web
Twitter lets pedophiles publicly discuss
their attraction to minors scholar
argues and then I said Twitter actively
protects and supports pedophilia this is
It's just overt and outright right now
yeah and the dude the fact that they
suspended your account for what you did
is literally that right I mean they're
more upset about you saying hey look at
what these people are doing then the
fact that people are doing that so they
are directly protecting these
individuals yep so that's right yeah I
get the vibe that when you're in a
culture war or any conflict really if
you establish vulnerability in your foe
you don't want to have fun with it
because then that gives them a time to
build up a defense mechanism towards it
so like this groomer narrative It's very
effective because people have been
grooming children sexually we see it on
you know in videos and crazy stuff but
if people just start LOL groomer groomer
groomer you start to see other people
establish an immune response and that's
what the Twitter admins have done by
saying you can't even call people
groomers Groomer's a neutral term
parents groom children to be great
people some people like grooming is just
getting someone ready to become
something and I think it's insane that
it's taken that people have forced it to
become this negative connotation we
should really be focusing on the
behavior and not what it's called they
decided that an actual word to describe
a a behavior is a slur imagine if
someone like uh skateboarded and then
you're like that's a skateboarder right
there and then the skateboarder was like
hey man don't call me that and then
Twitter was like we're gonna ban you if
you call them skateboarders it's like
they're literally doing it have you
gotten a temporary suspension before
nope this is the first in the history of
my Twitter career to ever it's almost
over your Twitter career is almost over
hey man it's been a big it's been a long
run it's been uh 13 13 years yeah yeah
I'm on 13 as well 2009 game that's right
yeah crazy right shout out but you know
there was a period where I took it
seriously and I would use Twitter to
report the news and post stories
now
I post a picture of a 96 foot tall
rooster that I got in Times Square big
beautiful rooster but with that said I
mean of course though I mean you you've
built a phenomenal platform outside of
it which 99.9 of people
don't have so in your case I mean if you
didn't use Twitter again like at this
stage you're you're good to go no but
the truth is I learned this the hard way
okay um Twitter was always a big mistake
also
when I got started doing news and
commentary I was like Wow Twitter is
this great place I should have been on
YouTube from the beginning I should have
started making YouTube videos instead I
was posting on Twitter because I was
convinced that people responding and
tweeting was legitimate conversation
and then it was only like two years
later I was like I should have started a
YouTube channel and I started a YouTube
channel and then I started building that
up and you can see here's the thing with
Twitter nobody ever walks up to me on
the street and goes you're that guy from
Twitter happens to me every day does it
really yep you you for real yeah not for
me yeah yeah I've had one it was after
Ferguson some guy some guy like actually
my neighbor was like hey man I saw you
on Twitter but since then it's always
YouTube it's always podcasts it's always
someone else's show and when I worked
for these big media companies they would
outright tell you this Twitter does not
drive traffic so we don't use it and I
was like what do you mean I was all like
no of course it does like everybody's
using Twitter and they were like bro and
they'd show me the metrics and Twitter
would drive like a tweet would get like
.01 clicks or something just like out of
the out of the the maybe my analytics
are like super mega High because the
difference is if you're using Twitter on
Twitter yeah that makes sense if you're
building a company and trying to use
Twitter as like a external tool it does
nothing for you
so being on Twitter okay no this is not
the case for me at all wow yeah this is
not the case that's surprising to me
yeah yeah yeah so like I'm way I'm way
bigger on Twitter than I am on YouTube
and I put more I spend more time on it
as well like I have a YouTube channel
and Instagram and Facebook
um but Twitter's the Twitter is the
biggest and Twitter does the most for my
actual business as well how does Twitter
generate revenue for you more than
YouTube I've sold tens of thousands of
things on Twitter wow merchandise books
well you mean promoting them on Twitter
not you're not directly selling them on
Twitter you're promoting yeah there's I
mean there's a link there's there's a
link but people are coming from Twitter
here's a question Twitter is the biggest
sales platform for my book for example
here's the question though yeah would
you be bigger on YouTube on any other
platform
um well I use Instagram I do use YouTube
I do use Facebook I use them all do you
have your own website yeah
that's interesting so maybe I'm an
anomaly um teamzubi.com
that's where I sell my my book my music
my merchandise but yeah for me Twitter
is the biggest traffic driver do you do
videos on Twitter yeah sometimes well I
will say this for me uh there's only one
thing I care about Twitter for and it's
that the my following list yeah I follow
left ring left wing right wing
journalists and news organizations and
it's just a really easy way to get a
news list that's the only thing I care
about so that's why I'm usually posting
nonsense the thing with social media is
different things are good for different
people like I know people who Instagram
is their that's their generator like
they get their clients their sales their
money like they get their money from
Instagram I know people wear it's
Facebook I know people it's Twitter I
know people it's YouTube
um so I think maybe just I think it just
varies from Individual to individual and
I think it's also what you like some
people like doing YouTube and some
people just like Twitter some people
like Instagram and I think if you like
something then you just go that much
well let's talk about the problem with
Twitter and where it's going with this
story is uh this is this is part of uh
um
whether it's intentional or not it was
explained to me by a former Trump
Administration official that what the
big tech companies Democrats the unit
party and Yukon types are trying to do
is
give anti-establishment people just
enough voice so there's no Ruckus but
reduce their voice just enough so it's
politically
uh neutered yeah it doesn't have an
impact in the long term so if you've got
a fierce rivalry rivalry between two
factions and suspending one would result
in an explosion of rage you do is you
suspend one percent now it's a lopsided
battle the left Gets A major advantage
against the right and the right slowly
loses out so when you do something like
this telling someone like me I can't say
a groomer to someone literally showing
kids you know adult materials
that's that's that is a big move a big
line jump so now on Twitter me getting
hit me talking about it how many people
do you think are gonna fall in line and
go oh yeah it's got a chilling effect
it's the same thing they did over the
past two and a half years they did it
during the Trump era and so on it's
creating that chill and um one of the
biggest issues that we have right now in
Western society and it's across the USA
it's in the UK it's in Canada it's
everywhere is just this climate of fear
like the the level of self-censorship
that is now happening I mean we can sit
here and we we can you know talk talk
openly and we're all open to sharing our
opinions but the sheer number of people
hundreds of millions of people who are
just scared to say what they think
whether they
go ahead oh no no oh yeah yeah yeah no
just just the the sheer number of people
who are just absolutely terrified to say
what they think on so many various
issues from politics to social stuff to
culture stuff to the entire pandemic
situation and
it it's it's concerning it's really
concerning especially because these are
places where you're supposed to have
free speech and if you cannot actually
exercise your freedom of speech then do
you really have it of course not and so
people seem to think
that uh well let me put it this way we
have the after hours uncensored show
over at timcast.com sign up we're going
to have one of one of those up tonight
at 11. and often we we do say things
that are alike we have conversations
that Twitter does that I'm sorry that
YouTube doesn't allow so we talked with
Marjorie Taylor green about the 2020
election and what the Republicans plan
to do if uh or I should say when they
win in November presumably and uh and we
talked about that I actually don't think
that conversation would get banned on
YouTube I'm just not willing to
entertain that it's it's an it's you
know because YouTube is their rules are
vague they're nebulous so the issue is
of course we don't want to be censored
we want to have the biggest
conversations possible with the most
people and people need to hear these
things and so it's a question of if we
have a hundred topics to talk about are
we forced to take one of those topics to
the website and that's the challenge
it's it's not it's not an easy decision
to make a lot of people are like Tim
sacrifice the presence on YouTube stop
doing the show altogether to make a
point and I'm like then how are we
winning anything yeah so that's the
challenge but here's what happens people
think that
we censor ourselves on the show to a
great degree not true at all there are
some things we will use innuendo for
dance around if it is like an overt
you're like going to get us shut down
we don't call people slurs we don't
swear I don't really have any any of
that stuff to worry about what you need
to understand is that
we say the things we believe in
and the people who said the things they
believe in got banned right so when
people refer to me as like a milk toast
fence sitter which is like the
long-running joke yes understand that
when they start Banning me
that's where the line has moved to
that's how far we're getting so it's not
that I sit here and I'm like I better
not say these things oh no I don't want
to anger YouTube is that I'll outright
say YouTube is dumb and says they'll
shut the show down if we say that so go
watch it on my website let's build up a
bigger website challenge all of these
systems it's the best we can do
I will say
the people who have opinions that are
overtly banned you're never going to
hear from them again they were banned on
YouTube already
so the way I described it before is that
you've got this big island and the it's
it's Cliffs all around that are slowly
being knocked down and eroded and I've
always been somewhat in the middle
but then you see people on the right the
cliffs are Road and they fall down as
censorship starts wiping them out
those people
held the line on their opinions
I didn't have to worry about it because
I'm like I'm not going to say the things
those guys are saying I don't agree with
them and now the cliffs ever wrote it to
the point where we're standing there
saying hey children shouldn't get sex
changes and they're like oh you better
watch out yep we're going to ban you if
you say that again yeah and then it's
going to come to a point where I'm like
well I'm saying it screw you and then
they ban me so this is a good example on
Twitter they said you can't call people
groomers fine I'll call them pedophiles
and I'll post all the stories I can find
where Twitter protected pedophiles
because I gotta wonder about the
leadership at Twitter that's enforcing
this stuff Vijaya got it I mean what's
her predilection what is she what is she
thinking about what is she interested in
that she would come to them and say I
don't want anyone to call out pedophiles
it's like I wonder why you would do that
it's really weird isn't it it's really
Sinister because with stuff like stuff
like this
it really should not be it shouldn't be
partisan it shouldn't be this it's not
it's not a political thing this
shouldn't be some left right issue
regardless of where you sit on the
political Spectrum during any remotely
same time or in any remotely sane
country everyone agrees there are
certain lines you do not cross when it
comes to children not anymore yeah and
the the fact that this is even
considered political or is becoming this
guy I'm like dude what is
what is going on this is it's it's very
worrying I don't think it's political so
much as it is just them letting go of
the pretense that they're a platform for
free expression like these platforms
like Twitter and YouTube used to really
value
appearing like they allow free
expression but now they've kind of given
up on that yeah for sure I'm talking
outside of Facebook and Twitter though
I'm talking as a general Society in a
culture right so with these issues it's
often framed as if this is you know
you've got these these these right
Wingers or these conservatives who have
a problem with stuff like this and
this is weird why does he want to come
out my water I thought he wasn't allowed
in here as long as you got your eyes on
him has he been grooming out there buddy
yeah so what you were saying anyway yeah
I was just saying that it that it's it's
nutty to me that this has even become
considered some kind of partisan split
and I think that there's this
reactionary thing that does happen
though where if there are you know if
people on the on the left side of the
aisle are doing something then there's a
reaction from certain people on the
right to oppose it regardless of what it
is and the opposite I think now that
people on conservatives are like wait
hang on why are you teaching my my child
about this nonsense why have you got
grown men in women's outfits reading to
children and exposing themselves or
whatever and there are there's a faction
of people on the left side of the aisle
they were like oh well conservatives
have an issue with this so I now need to
support it thanks for checking out this
clip from timcast IRL come hang out live
Monday through Friday at 8 pm Eastern
Time Super Chat will even answer some of
your questions if you want to check out
the after hours censored show go to
timcast.com and become a member we put
those up Monday through Thursday at 11
PM they're very funny not very family
friendly we'll love to see you there
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time